mein kampf ça veut dire mon combat ma
lutte c'est un livre idéologique
politique publié par adolf hitler en
1925 le premier volume et en 1926 le
deuxième volume
il
qui
adolf hitler c'est un ancien combattant
de la première guerre mondiale
quelqu'un qui a eu différents échecs
dans sa jeunesse cet homme a décidé
d'entrer en politique en 1919 et il a
participé à la naissance d'un mouvement
qui est le parti des travailleurs
allemands puis le parti national
socialiste des travailleurs allemands et
il a tenté de faire un coup d'état
en 1923 le coup d'état échoué il a été
arrêté il est placé en prison à partir
du 11 novembre 1933 et c'est dans cette
prison de landsberg dans la banlieue de
munich
c'est dans cette prison qui va concevoir
le projet d'écrire un livre idéologique
qui définisse son mouvement et qui
définissent aussi son parcours
[Musique]
il
mein kampf c'est un texte qui
composaient en deux temps il ya un
premier temps c'est un parcours un
parcours individuel de hitler qui
raconte sa jeunesse dans sa famille qui
évoque sa mère qui évoque son père dans
cette première partie
il ya ensuite la guerre moment énorme
pour hitler puisque il fait partie des
enthousiastes qui vont s'engager au
premier jour de la guerre pour aller
combattre le deuxième volume il a été en
réalité publié un an plus tard dans ce
deuxième volume ce qu'il fait c'est
qu'il détaille son idéologie chapitre
après chapitre
et il explique comment il est anti
marxiste comment il est antisémite
comment il est raciste
comment il a un peuple a besoin d'un
espace vital comment il faut mettre en
place une propagande pour convaincre le
plus grand nombre et ainsi avoir un pays
qui puisse se tenir et être notamment
derrière son leader politique derrière
son führer mein kampf est clairement
voulu comme un programme politique
selon lui il ya des ennemis puissants
qui luttent contre l'eau rédaction que
le redressement de l'allemagne
ce sont les français les anglais les
américains et puis il y à une race qui
luttent contre la race allemande c'est
lara juifs contre la rage saharienne
donc vous avez compris que c'était un
livre qui est raciste au sens fort au
sens premier
c'est pour cela que mein kampf a été
interdit au lendemain la seconde guerre
mondiale
dans beaucoup d'états parce que le
racisme je vous rappel n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit
dans mein kampf
il n'y a rien qui laisse voir la shoah
il n'y a pas de description net de ce
qui va se passer par la suite il a
l'idée qu'il faut se débarrasser des
juifs qu'il faut les enlever de la
société les éliminer mais il ne dit pas
ni comment ni qui ni ce qu'il va faire
ni la manière dont ça s'est déroulé dans
mein kampf
ce qu'il ya c'est un projet pour se
débarrasser des juifs et des slaves et
de fait crée un espace vital pour le
peuple allemand c'est ça que hitler va
mettre en oeuvre à partir de 1938
hitler n'est pas n'importe qui quand il
est en prison en 1924 1925 le directeur
de la prison et c'est de daran j'ai un
peu son séjour on lui permet de
fréquenter ses anciens comparses du coup
d'état il est en cellule avec un
personnage assez important qui s'appelle
rudolf hess qui va être son secrétaire s
a obtenu d'avoir une petite machine en
prison hitler lui dicté le texte de mein
kampf et c'est ainsi qu'on a un premier
tapuscrit qui va être ensuite revu relu
par différentes personnalités proches du
mouvement
[Musique]
au moment où le livre sort en 1925 1926
c'est pas un vrai succès on réussit à
peine à épuiser la première impression
qu'on pense que c'est à peu près dix
mille exemplaires qui ont été vendus
c'est un livret qui était un peu cher à
l'époque qu'il y passe qui dépassait les
10 marques donc ce n'était pas ce
n'était pas donné
et puis ensuite c'est un livre qui va
connaître un succès en réalité parallèle
à celui du mouvement nazi
plus le mouvement nazi augmente dans les
urnes plus les ventes de mein kampf
augmente si bien que le livre connaît
son plus grand succès à partir du moment
où hitler accède au pouvoir en 1933
à partir de là effectivement beaucoup
d'allemands se disent qu'ils veulent
savoir ce que le livre contient qui
veulent comprendre qui elle et adolf
hitler quel est le national socialisme
et en 1935 sont adoptées des lois les
lois de nuremberg qui établissent le
racisme en doctrine absolue au sein du
troisième reich avec la séparation entre
les races avec la race aryenne d'une
part et la race juive de l'autre des
métiers qui sont interdits d'exercice
pour les juifs donc on est dans un plein
antisémitisme et à partir de ce moment
là on préconise de donner aux jeunes
couples qui se marient mein kampf en
cadeau de mariage de la part de l'état
mais pour qu'ils sachent qu'ils ne
doivent pas souiller le sens de la race
aryenne et qui ne doivent pas faire de
mariages mixtes
cette première publication en fait elle
est faite par quelqu'un qui était à
l'extrême droite et qui était anti
allemand qui s'appelle ferme en solo et
sort l'eau il a un objectif qui est
celui notamment des anciens combattants
français de la première guerre mondiale
ou d'hommes comme le maréchal lyautey
c'est de faire savoir à quel point
hitler est anti français c'est ça son
objectif il ya l'antisémitisme bien sûr
y'a l'anticommunisme mais la question
clé c'est pas ça s'est montré qu'il
existe en allemagne un mouvement
violemment puissamment anti-français et
qu'il va falloir agir que si on n'est
pas conscient de ça on va un moment
donné se faire écraser toute l'histoire
du nazisme aurait pu être la même sans
l'existence de ce livre de mein kampf
il faut pas surévaluer ce livre c'est le
mouvement nazi qui fait l'histoire
ce n'est pas le livre qu réécrit
l'histoire donc il faut pas sacraliser
le livre faut pas en faire un espèce
d'objet absolue qui contiendrait le mal
absolu qui se serait répandu à partir du
livre
non c'est pas ça c'est une organisation
deux militants fortement structuré très
puissante et très violente qui a imposé
sa vision du monde à l'histoire
cette vision du monde était en partie
écrit dans ce livre